a sad update to a story we first brought
you last week
alexander the german shepherd that was
stabbed several times has sadly died
thank you for joining us at 11 i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez the animal
foundation was helping care for
alexander and staff say he was hurt
protecting his owner arko mana joining
us now live near charleston and durango
with new details in this case orco
yeah denise and bryan metro police say
that the attack happened at one of the
homes here
on this street in the west valley this
is pavia drive which again is near
charleston and durango investigators say
someone stabbed a dog
and a man who lived there and then ran
off neighbors we spoke to can't believe
this happened
so close to home to have somebody just
like go off on a dog like that is
unbelievable a community shocked and
saddened to hear about the death of a
furry friend
a german shepherd named alexander died
after a brutal attack last week metro
police saying someone stabbed the dog as
well as a man
at a home on this west valley street
rally sanders lives in the neighborhood
and is an owner of two dogs
they're here to not only protect us but
to
love us maybe this guy this german
shepherd was just trying to protect his
owner
sanders still processing what happened
it bothers me big time
you know people are just you know
no respect for anything anymore the
animal foundation did their best to take
care of alexander over the weekend
according to the shelter alexander did
not make it
because his injuries were too severe he
suffered from multiple stab wounds
to his side neck and legs it's a very
sad thing that it happened
some neighbors are now concerned for
their safety it makes us
even more scared you know apparently
this neighbor
this neighborhood is pretty safe it's
just like we don't know what's safe
anymore
their message now is to stay vigilant to
prevent another
terrible tragedy you see something
strange say something call somebody
that's why we have police
metro police say the injuries to the man
are non-life-threatening
investigators add this is an open case
and they are still searching for the
person responsible
reporting live in las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now